hey everybody International Master Danny
wrench here for chest comms YouTube
channel and today I wanted to start a
new series on the topic of chess
strategy as a general umbrella to talk
to you about pawns and pawn vocabulary
the recognition of pawn weaknesses and
pawn strengths and in general just
everything concerning the little guys of
chess let's go ahead and get started
in part one our main goal is to
basically improve our pawn vocabulary
the ability to look at a chess board and
recognize what is and what isn't upon
weakness the first and most common type
of pawn weakness that occurs in a lot of
chess games are doubled pawns a double
pawn is any time you have two pawns
stacked on top of each other where one
pawn left another file via capture
double pawns cannot happen outside of
capture to land right on top of a
brother pawn like this now double pawns
are not always the worst thing in the
world because by definition when you
left a file that left an open file for
other pieces what pieces love open files
ding ding ding rook you're a genius
aren't you Oh so sometimes capturing
toward the center in a situation where
you open up a rook or capturing away
from the center in a position that might
open up a file in the center of the
board can be advantageous to you but
double pawns themselves are never a good
thing they don't protect each other they
step on each other's toes as you try to
advance up the board and if they're
isolated when you look over to the
e-file here which means they're doubled
so they got on top of each other one way
or another via capture but there are no
ponds around them to help protect them
like there are here with the C pawn
protecting the b-pawn that means these
particular double pawns are very weak
and usually sitting ducks targets for
the enemy pieces so if we had to rank
double pawns from worse to best we would
say that the worst type of double pawns
are isolated I guess you could say
triple pawns possibly if you ever had
three or even four pawns I've seen
stacked on top of each other but those
cases are much more rare so double pawns
that are isolated are really a problem
and by themselves never really a good
thing though even in those cases by
definition you do usually have open
files because you wouldn't have doubled
pawns if you hadn't captured from one
file to another double pawns that still
have the protection of another pawn and
are basically still a part of a larger
pawn mass are not necessarily great in
and of themselves but they're really not
that bad
in comparison you see two healthy pawns
right next to each other can advance up
the board protecting each other and
that's why healthy pawns are always
better than unhealthy pawns let's talk
about the next pawn weakness here we're
going to talk about the isolated pawn
particularly it's on the D file I'm
going to quickly show you an opening
right after we introduce all three of
the pawn weaknesses I'm trying to get
across today that can commonly reach an
isolated queen pawn usually a pawn on
the D file is referred to as an i QP
isolated Queen pawn and isolated pawn by
definition is well isolated right all
alone meaning there are no pawns on the
adjacent files the pawn itself is never
again like double pawns if you're
evaluating just the unbiased factors of
the pawn itself it's not great it's
alone it can only be protected by the
pieces but generally when you have an
isolated pawn you have open files and
usually that pawn is actually advanced
far enough that it's kind of an asset in
the center it controls critical squares
often you have a little bit more space
and you can even use the diagonals
around the pawn to potentially create
attacking chances many times isolated
queen pawn positions are very dynamic
and double-edged lots of good play for
both sides so an isolate upon itself
again never that great but an isolated
pawn in a middle game with our lots of
pieces can actually not be the worst
thing in the world the final type of
pawn weakness I want to point out today
which again the first part here part one
our first installment is all about
learning to look at a chess board and
recognize pawn weaknesses and the bigger
picture this all this knowledge is going
to be really useful for you guys because
one thing a chess player needs is the
skill to look at a chess board and sort
of see the forest through the trees see
the bigger picture the smoke through the
mirrors if you will and so you're not
always caught up on all the tactics of
the pieces but your ability to sort of
see where the position might be headed
is based on what long term weaknesses
you have and pawns are always dictating
those factors because pawns are the only
pieces that can't go back so everything
they do is technically long term so
again in other parts we're going to look
at the pawn assets and eventually look
at pawn play and these are very quick
snippets to a much longer running video
series I actually have over on chest
comm which is pawn structure 101 so
there's a long standing much more
in-depth video series here this is sort
of fast-paced and just sort of hits you
in the noggin and knock you out and give
you a little more knowledge but anyway
just I'm just trying to tell you that so
that you have an idea of why exactly it
is you
looking at a chessboard with no other
pieces besides the pawns and so in this
case we set up one enemy pawn just to
highlight the third and final weakness
of today's video which is that the pawn
on b2 is a backward pawn a backward pawn
by definition is a pawn that cannot
advance due to capture moving it once
would run into a capture here whereas
moving at twice would run into capture
via on passant in passing if you don't
know what Amazon is then check out our
YouTube video lectures and I believe we
have a video describing on pass on one
capture one move would allow regular
capture while two moves would allow
capture via on pass on a backward pawned
that is action on an open file and the
target to enemy pieces like a rook is a
really big weakness almost just as bad
as an isolated pawn or even isolate
double pawns so a backward pawn is not
something you want but it does happen
commonly in structures one extreme case
of backward pawns might be something
like this where you see that the one
black pawn before technically if you
were evaluating this unbiased Lee
forgetting about the fact that the
position here is completely illegal
almost and highly improbable you would
if you're just looking at the pawns you
would see that one move allows the
capture to move again on passant the
same on this side of the board which
means essentially this pawn on b4 is
worth just as much as all three of these
pawns if not for other factors so that's
not really practical because there are
always other factors but your ability to
look at pawn weaknesses and see the
future of a position is maybe based on
looking at weaknesses and weak squares
surrounding pawns like this and so this
type of knowledge and the ability to
recognize double pawns
isolated pawns and backward pawns can be
really useful in part two but we'll do
is we'll show practical examples of how
double pawns isolated pawns and backward
pawns can occur quickly in very common
openings that you may be playing right
now and you didn't even know it right so
there you go hope you enjoyed this video
here on a youtube channel
if anybody's wondering about my live
sessions and bullet brawls I decided to
start letting people know that you can
follow me on twitter at daniel wrench
and I usually make announcements when
I'm going to be playing those sessions
over on chess comm so if you want to
follow or even have a chance to be a
part of one of those games go ahead and
and do that hope you enjoyed this video
and I'll see you around on chess comm